[Music]
okay everybody so this is my
spoiler review of fear street part
1 1994 this was directed by lee
yenyak and written by lee yenyak and
also written by phil grazaday okay so i
have so many conflicting emotions about
this film i was super hyped about it and
what's so interesting about this film is
that it
has such amazing elements of suspense in
it
it has great shocks in it and it also
has really good twists in it and i also
think that
it being a slasher horror it's hard to
pull off the sequences without getting
bored during them or getting repetitive
but i think the strongest thing about
this film is how
well it does its sequences with the
killers in them
now where i had some issues it was more
evident in the beginning of this film
was
some of the songs in it i thought all
the song choices were good but they were
too close together and
really jarring there's a scene where our
main character of dean is on the bus
and it goes from insane in the membrane
to creep by radiohead to a somber song
at the memorial service
literally within 30 seconds of each
other so that was just way too crammed
in and felt
just like it was forcing things in
really quick you also feel that just
with the editing through this film
and it's so hard when you judge editing
right because you don't know if it's
really on the editor or if it's on the
lack of coverage that the
director had gotten and you see a lot
you know these things i just noticed
they kind of are blaring a little more
though in this type of movie where
things aren't syncing up right and
there's a lot of continuity errors
in the editing that could also be you
know a continuity script supervisor
mistake there's a lot of reasons that
can happen but again things just don't
match right so there's just a lot of
bizarre editing in this film but what i
really enjoyed about this story was it's
really good as a first movie i think
it's refreshing that it's a trilogy that
goes in reverse i think that's cool and
unique especially for this genre
and i also think that it's really doing
a good job at building the story about
the witch and the lore and kind of
getting you hyped for the next film and
then the film
even after that when we go to 1966 with
this pastor we hear about
and there was moments that worked so
well scenes that work
so well in this film that remind you of
other films you've seen before
you'll feel that screen vibe in that
scene with dina towards the beginning
where the doorbell keeps ringing and the
killer outside is watching her and
stalking her and then it goes to kate's
house i thought that whole sequence felt
such like a love larger scream and it
worked really well and was
really effectively done and there's a
nuance to it where
all the pacing is really on in these
type of intense sequences to really make
you feel
on the edge of your seat and i also felt
one of the standout moments of suspense
was actually towards the end
when they're connecting all the dots
while they're in this room and the
killer's trying to get in and they're
figuring out that sam needs to die
it felt like the scene from the goonies
with the bone organ that's how intense
it was because you have
these characters trying to quickly
figure out a puzzle in their brain
while something's trying to kill them so
i thought that was a standout scene for
me
now where i'm really conflicted is is
simon
a good comic relief or is he over the
top is he try hard
i still don't know i didn't even know
why i was watching
it i thought there was moments that were
cringe but that could even go to the
writing where the line he says
pervert in a panty shop you know it's
overwritten where they're like
dropping joke after joke on top of each
other where it's feeling forced but then
there's moments i thought were actually
pretty hysterical like when
everyone's having their moments of love
but he's in the bathroom by himself and
they insinuate that he
masturbated to himself i thought that
was hysterical but when i'm talking
about shocks i love
i could not believe that we ended up
seeing kate we kind of
get attached to and start to really like
and she got a lot of screen time too
so i was shocked that she you know was
sliced up that was
a surprise that i was not feeling these
type of surprises in films in a long
time most are usually set up
miles away but those two deaths with her
and then simon getting the axes had
really shocked me and i thought were
really really effective
but where there was some writing issues
from our main lens in
dina dina being her main character is
that it almost felt
silly how the father who's an alcoholic
is mentioned but we never
see him i think like if you compare it
to a similar movie in it
that with the girl in it we see very
important character moments with her
father and it really makes you
sympathize with her where
with dina when she has these big moments
with sam and it will go to the end where
she mentions that father and she's not
really going to be like him
and she had visions that she was when
she wasn't with sam that would have felt
more powerful
if we just had a moment to meet this guy
and kind of really see it from dina's
lens what she's
going through so that was frustrating
and i also thought what was odd was
in the beginning they had dina and josh
feel like siblings but i felt like
middle of this movie they forgot they
were siblings and it didn't feel that
way in particular i think a big missed
moment of that was
that took me out of the film believe it
or not was when kate kissed
josh in front of his sister you know and
dina has no reaction like that is
something that a sibling would always
have a reaction to so
that was weird i just felt like there
was a point where like it wasn't played
like they were siblings enough it was
very odd to me
and i did like that it was campy and it
knew what it was
but that still doesn't let it get away
with some really just not great cliches
and one of those big ones is the cpr
revival that happens here
where sam spits out the water and you're
waiting for her to get back to life it's
done to death in films it's it's like a
no-no
don't do that anymore there's got to be
a different way to have her come back so
that was a little disappointing but
overall
most of this stuff was fresh in this
film which i really appreciated and i
think how they wrote sam's character arc
was really
well done and paid off and how she comes
around to not being afraid to show her
judgmental mother who she really is by
kissing
dina in front of her mom and also that
we got that payoff of that she's not
afraid now to
show her true self to the world so that
i thought worked well
i really like how this film ended and i
think that continues with the shock here
and that it worked and it wasn't just
shocking to shock that you know it was
crazy to me when
c german calls again and that is gillian
jacobs here
and this is leading into the sequel
right and she's like it's not over it's
never over this is why i'm comparing it
to it with pennywise it's very similar
in that sense
and how they talk about this witch you
can't stop her she makes the rules
and that you know big shocking moment
that sam comes downstairs and possessed
by the witch again we get this like
exorcist moment and i love they played
some sound garden here
the day i tried to live it's a perfect
throw to the character of sam
and that she's in that situation of
trying to live
and it leaves that nice cliffhanger of
dina saying i'm going to get you back to
sam while she's possessed and having
that nice post-credits moment with
gillian jacobs character and that we're
gonna see her younger self in the sequel
here so it hyped you up for that which
is next week
also going to this music i love in this
film that they've chosen
not just sound garden but even opening
the film with nine inch nails is never a
bad choice
also having garbage and i love this
white zombie
credit music they usually also use in
the trail i think it's a perfect feeling
vibe for this trilogy but i'm one of
those people out of horror sub genres
slashers are my least favorite
a lot of them i feel get repetitive i
get sick of it i don't feel the
suspension i need to but
what the bright spot of this film is
that is its main goal is to be a good
slasher horror film and i think it is
a very good slasher horror film but if
we're going
general film and story it's very okay
and
i think that's the disappointing part of
it but i'm actually shocked because it's
been
years for me since i feel like i've
enjoyed the vibes of slasher har
and scenes that really felt me on the
edge of my seat so i think that's a huge
success
for that in this film because that's
something not many films have
accomplished recently so i'm gonna give
it that
but i do think there was more potential
here and that if they had paid a little
more attention to dina's character
and given us a little more in her shoes
and maybe have a stronger comic relief
character and maybe that's just by how
the writing was for his character but
it did feel a lot of force humor
sometimes so overall
i'm still very excited about the next
film i thought this was pretty good i'm
gonna give this one an 8.1
i'm excited to see what number two is
gonna turn out we're gonna have sadie
sync now from stranger things
be the focus here so it's gonna be
interesting to see how she does and then
we're gonna have the third one the
following week so please make sure to
subscribe to see
all my reviews of fear street but what i
want to know right now is what you
thought of this film
let's see it down below and also if you
haven't seen it yet
i had interviewed the actress of sam in
this film olivia welch who was brilliant
i
interviewed her when she was just on the
show panic so please check that out it's
a really fun interview you can kind of
get to know more about her and please
follow me at steve varley show
on twitter instagram for more of me and
i'll see you next time